vous nous emmenez en italie charles ou
bas les hommes n'aiment pas le rose les
policiers en colère montre des masques
roma il réclamait pourtant des masques
ffp2 mais quand ils ont ouvert les
cartons surprise des masques livret
était rose et ça pour les syndicats de
policiers italiens ça ne passe pas ou
bien on dirait distille une mauvaise
blague je peux vous garantir que nous ne
porterons pas ces masques car notre
uniforme mérite le respect dit l'un des
syndicalistes
selon certains il serait impossible
d'avoir une fonction d'autorité avec des
masques rose la polémique fait les gros
titres en italie à tel point que le
gouvernement a officiellement réagi en
espérant leur expliquant que le respect
pour l'uniforme ne vient pas des
couleurs mais du comportement et du
travail des hommes et des femmes qui
portent cet uniforme résultat ce sont
les syndicats d'enseignants italien qui
nous ont récupérés ont accepté de
récupérer tous ces masses mais la vérité
moins de problèmes de virilité chez les
pros final il n'y a pas de différence
entre une fille et un garçon
on est tous égaux
je préfère être une fille parce qu'on a
un peu plus de caractère
on prend soin de nous et on a des beaux
habits et tout ça pour moi une fille
c'est beaucoup plus calme c'est beaucoup
plus lente et plus intelligent
m
[Musique]
elle était une figure en république
tchèque hana orca 57 ans chanteuse du
groupe assonances a été emporté par le
comice après avoir volontairement
contracté la maladie auprès de sa
famille alors qu'elles n'étaient pas
vaccinés anti-vaccins elle voulait être
contaminées pour obtenir son passé des
terres son mari et son fils étaient eux
vacciner comme il ya les anciens souche
les anciennes souche qui circulent
encore il y à des réservoirs amis m'ont
actuellement les cervidés aux états-unis
au canada david ne peux pas les citer
d'avoir des cordes mais cerveau vite si
vous êtes vacciné et vous avez eu la
qu'ovide au féminin la commune doit
comme tout ce qui fait les chiffres
jeudi à président oui je le pense pas
quoi oui ça parce que tout de suite
évidemment il ya des protestations de
suite là quand je dis j'ai vu la coved
c'est féminin comme tout ce qui touche
la salle mendès et je dis je le pense
pas parfois j'ai je dis des choses j'ai
créé des choses uniquement pour eux
énervée marlène schiappa tu avais le
mari j'ai 28 ans et je suis ingénieur de
formation et je suis la fondatrice de
puissantes de qui je suis impuissant
puissante secteur où là c'est pour nous
ça éric
donc puissante c'est une entreprise de
vivre ma soeur aujourd'hui on est venu
vous voir à bâle
est ce que c'est que jamais de super
bonne humeur et fabi brin mai
elle a vraiment sonné ou
non vraiment c'est pas c'est pas c'est
parce que tu crois toi je te
jeter génie regarder
non ça ne se met pas la bande à corps ça
ne sert pas ça jo bats je pensais que ça
se mette à mon couchepin mais ceci dit
maintenant qu n'ont pas aujourd'hui du
coup on vient vous présenter le premier
vibro de la marque donc qui s'appelle
conques envahissante et qui a la
particularité en fait dos pieds la
partie externe du clitoris et qui peut
ou non se plier pour pénétrer et vivrez
hockey
marc soit pas gêné comme ça enfin je
suis pas chez moi je vois tu je vois
très bien qu est-ce que ce qu'est ce que
c'est un moyen aussi scène qu'est ce que
tu aimes bien chez moi chez carlin qui
prend des décisions et sa j'adore
j'aime bien avoir compris contre des
décisions moi je n'aime pas trop faire
marcher son cerveau
tu vois ah ouais ouais bah on va pas
vraiment s'attendre ouais et là je vois
tant que noir schisteux retour
à
c'est un truc de fou
sheila cher dangereux
moi je trouve l'objet très
ergonomique joli prix fous le tester
j'en ai bien ben écoute j'ai envie de te
dire fais toi plaisir
[Musique]
si tu es à l'aise à ton rythme on enlève
le bas
timminco la grand-mère au web c'est
grave ou pas on a droit d'être confort
dans ses sous vêtements non mais du coup
pourquoi tu appelles ça une flotte de
grand mère c'est vraiment ma grand mère
s'est accusée de ta grand'mère faute de
voler c'est génial bon on va voir ce que
ça a donné
aa c'est ça ouais
sincèrement ça ressemble plus un script
en moi je ne le mettrais pas il est
totalement troué de partout france est
fabuleux si je puis me permettre
c'est pas la fête du slip non surtout
vous dire aujourd'hui
je crois que je ne fais pas de politique
je m'en fous voilà de tout ça mais
valérie pécresse est un petit peu mon
délire je suis bien ici
je ne compte pas lui payer sa compagne
de pouvoir parce que vous avez ségolène
royal
alors elle a détrôné de loin ségolène
royal liberté c'est celle que vous avez
eue pour créer la famille qui vous
ressemble et dans laquelle vous
inscrivez l'amour et le respect je dois
vous remercier car avec votre arrivée
notre village a fait un bond
considérable au niveau démographique
275 habitants le sable passé à 188 soit
une augmentation de plus de 7% vous avez
un doux pour choisir les prénoms de vos
enfants ah oui est ce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas vrai alors j'ai fait mes
enfants j'ai jamais répondu à la
question moi je crois qu'on me la posent
il faut la poser la gamme à des gens qui
sont très à coeur dans la rue qui me
disent ne pouvait pas faire ça
psychologiquement ça va engendrer des
d'être au match comme un sérieux mais
lionel qui s'appelle vic et non
s'est-elle team donc ça fait dix
victimes c'est vrai ou c'est 10 minutes
y faisait maintenant ce sont ce sont des
diminutifs de piémont mais je trouve ça
drôle de les appeler dans la rue
victimes venaient là à cet hommage
unanime à l'acteur gaspard ulliel mort à
37 ans après un accident de ski survenu
hier vers 16 heures à la station de
larosière en savoie et il est entré en
collision avec un autre skieur surdoué
du cinéma il avait notamment incarné
yves saint laurent à l'écran et avait
été récompensé à deux reprises aux
césars ce soir le monde du cinéma est
bouleversé